obviously we know you have a new last
name but this is your first official
credit my last name is the same I'm just
adding more okay we're adding the
addition but this is your first official
credit as Priyanka Chopra Jonas what
does it feel like to see that on the
right yeah this is the the one that goes
down is like the first project that
comes out how does it feel are your
knees doing it about that clearly not
look at my oh my gosh that just made it
official I guess now that it's in my
credit jeez okay no clearly not used to
it it's I guess a very very fitting
because I got married during this movie
while I was filming this movie in fact
four days after I finished filming it so
it's fitting that this is the first one
and also this is my first credit as a
producer in a hindi movie in Hindi
language movie so that's a cool yeah so
look it's all like it's very fitting
that it happened at this time with this
movie so four days before my wedding I
was like fighting with my husband and
like stressed out about getting my
parents to the airport you were filming
a movie that's like the ultimate
Priyanka move if like the most
overachiever like busy woman on the go
that's true but the good thing about
that was that Nick had come down to
India because he was handling logistical
things while with the wedding planners
while I was finishing the movie and he
was he came to set and he used to come
to set and visit just for a little bit
go back so having him around I think
yeah my brain was like I this is all
good I don't have to stress out he's
handling he's doing the heavy lifting
and we like that's the best thing about
our relationship is when he's working I
do it when I'm working he does it
there's a that's something we adora
understand about each other that our
work is of precedence to us you know so
it was amazing to see that I love that
we did that first that first ever
Thanksgiving they couldn't be in America
with his family because we were filming
so Nick came down so he's very the very
first Thanksgiving as a couple was in
Delhi you flew in a turkey from
we shot all day and then we went in
party then on Thanksgiving we were doing
the Bhangra together Nick and I on the
dance floor that's not as obnoxious as
it is this is a duo this is a boss-lady
duo I I can tell that you have this
amazing connection but what does it mean
to be here as this little power duo
having the only Asian film at the gap
it's a huge deal it's it's just
fantastic
this is my third film back at it but to
be in the gala and the only Asian film
was so exciting when we heard that news
it was such an honor
this film is I can't explain it but
special on so many levels
not just because of what it talks about
and how real that is to me but also the
fact that I feel like it's a little bit
of my own because I'm producing it with
two of my closest friends we've done six
movies together these guys that Ronnie
Screwvala and Cedric poor and just to
like work with this genius lot of people
the actors that we had fir'aun's I wrote
it like it was just like acting school
so you know when there was a there was a
freedom to just coming to set and
knowing that we could collaborate we
could talk about things how we wanted to
do it everybody was on the same page
there was just such an ease to making
the movie even though it was a hot very
difficult movie to make production wise
and performance wise but if there was
just an ease with each other which i
think is what you're saying you when you
see the movie you can tell that it was
like a labor of love like everyone's
just bringing their a-game and like
really committed the mushy doesn't let
you bring them b games like have it on
bad okay well losses at the core of this
film but the mother-daughter
relationship and we've met your mom many
times at ET on the carpet with you she's
frequently your date to big events how
much of the quirks of that relationship
did you pull in um my mother and I were
more like we're like friends we we've
always been like friends we hang out
together I think what I did the
commonality between other teens
character and my relationship with my
mother is my mom's fiercely protective
and
about my well-being nothing else matters
except me smiling me being happy and my
well-being and she can be like if she
sees me not being happy or troubled or
tormented about something she gets like
ferocious she doesn't she doesn't sit
back and she doesn't feel bad or she
won't have the conversation she like
needs to fix things yeah I love that and
other these characters like that so if
her daughter needs something or
something needs to happen she's not
passive she's like active she's she's
like yeah she kept saying tigress but
she's just like nothing matters whatever
I need to do make sure her well-being
and she lives the happiest best biggest
longest life and that was that something
so common between my mom and a disease
carry meaning even if you have to wrap a
sweater off a mannequin you know what I
mean in this movie is real oh I love
that it's so funny
speaking of fashion vogue India name
this photoshoot and cover is next-level
even for you the fashionista of all
fashion in the interview you said that
both homes and babies are on your to-do
list how many homes how many babies
babies as many as God would give us I
think that's not something that we can
ever we can ever say I love kids I
always have loved kids I've advocated
for kids all my life they're my favorite
people in the planet so like as many as
I can and the same thing with homes the
end of this movie there's this funeral
scene and she's wearing like the
colorful bright colors and everyone else
is in white and I just love that because
even though she's a character and this
is a movie I felt like this was a
Priyanka kind of thing because you're
always your fashion I mean you and Nick
what does it feel like to be like named
the best-dressed woman in the world in
like every magazine that matters I mean
lost I just want to say on that before
you go to fashion because our on my at
my son's funeral
I wore a vibrant red color and that's
what I wanted I brought in the script
and I wanted to bring to the film that
people should celebrate death to like
death days are like
and so that's why I'm had that guy to
wear a Vibram annulus and there are like
that's the only two constants in life
right birth and death is what you know
but come in fashion it's a lot of
pressure yeah cuz now I'm like okay I
love playing oh yeah
getting dressed I love clothes but thank
God I have amazing Cyrus I mean me me um
in America who handles everything that I
wear thank God for her yeah aesthetic
and thank God that she understands what
I like I'm very moody when it comes to
the clothes I want to wear I have to be
comfortable in it I don't like the
uncomfortable in my clothes but I also
like to be put together so if I didn't
have her in my life you would only see
me in sweats they'd be matching sweats
hmm but they don't mean a sweat suit
with Jonas Brothers t-shirt that is true
you know what I mean yeah best thing
that happened on the Internet in the
last month was you photoshopping
yourself after that photo
can we talk about where that all came
from I mean Priyanka entertaining us all
I think I was gonna do anything myself I
was sick that big home which is why I
couldn't go to the VMAs and it was it
was supposed to be this fun night where
all six of us got together because we
never really get to do it very often
because all of us have crazy schedules
and now that the boys are on tour we
meet like as a six of us so this was
supposed to be that like fun thing we
had dinner planned after and then I was
really unwell and I think Nick felt bad
that he was there and I was unwell and
like I was watching it from my couch at
home and that when they won and like
just seeing his face I felt like oh I
was like I felt like I let him down at
that point because I should have been
there but I was so I'm so sick and I saw
it on his face and I just like this is
technology that's the reason why I love
technology right is it doesn't matter if
I was at the hair or not on their neck
sure makes it look like I was
you